Der Abbau von Rohstoffen auf dem Mond Hinrgespinnst
oder realistischer Plan?
Helium 3 ist der Stoff, der als Treibstoff
für Fusionsreaktoren hier auf der Erde fungieren
könnte.
Das Isotop soll von Robotern auf dem Mond
abgebaut und dann zur Erde transportiert werden.
Neben einigen privaten Unternehmen will auch
China dieses sogenannte “Moonmining” verwirklichen.
Wie sehen die Pläne konkret aus und wie realistisch
ist das Vorhaben wirklich?
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es jeden
Tag spannende Sciencevideos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr kein Video herzlich
willkommen!
Ihr habt Euch dieses Thema bei bei Whats App
gewünscht.
Hier ist es!
Chinas Pläne im Weltall sind groß und alles
läuft auf eine permanente Mondstation hinaus.
Eines der größten Ziele dabei ist die Suche
nach Bodenschätzen, vor allem Helium 3.
Es besteht aus einem Neutron und zwei Protonen
und ist ein gigantischer Energieträger.
Mit einer Tonne des Isotops könnte eine 7-Millionen-Einwohner-Stadt
wohl ein Jahr lang mit Strom versorgt werden.
Der Wert von helium 3 ist also immens.
Der Aufwand für den Abbau auf dem Mond könnte
sich tatsächlich rechnen.
Helium 3 kommt auf der Erde kaum vor.
Denn es stammt aus dem Sonnenwind, der den
Mond aufgrund seines fehlenden Magnetfeldes
gut erreicht - und so kann sich das Helium-3
dort anlagern.
Das Isotop eignet sich hervorragend als Brennstoff
für die Kernfusion.
Bei der Fusion mit dem Wasserstoffisotop Deuterium
beispielsweise entstünde als Endprodukt Helium
4.
Der große Vorteil: Es entsteht keine radioaktive
Strahlung.
Einen kleinen Nachteil gibt es aber auch - zumindest
derzeit: Denn bislang sind noch keine Reaktoren
entwickelt worden, in denen das Helium-3 verbrannt
werden könnte.
Keiner der Reaktoren hat eine positive Energiebilanz,
denn das große Problem: Es braucht sehr hohen
Druck und Temperaturen, um zwei positiv geladene
Atomkerne zu verschmelzen.
Und das ist mit heutiger Technik NOCH nicht
möglich.
Doch auch eine andere Eigenschaft von Helium
3 könnte von großer Bedeutung sein, denn
es eignet sich auch für den Bomben-Bau und
seine Sprengkraft ist gigantisch!
Zudem wäre auch eine weitere Anwendung spannend
und zwar in der Raumfahrt selbst.
Raumschiffe könnten mit einem Fusionstriebwerk
mit Deuterium und Helium-3 sehr viel schneller
unterwegs sein: Statt vier Jahre hin und zurück
würde eine Reise zum Mars nur noch etwa drei
Monate dauern.
Aber auch für Kühlmittel und Messinstrumente
wird Helium 3 benötigt.
Und so gibt es einige Unternehmen, die sich
mit dem sogenannten “Moonmining” beschäftigen.
Neben Helium 3 sind es übrigens auch noch
andere wertvolle Rohstoffe, die uns auf den
Mond locken: beispielsweise Iridium und andere
seltene Metalle, die sich durch Meteoriteneinschläge
angereichert haben.
Neben privaten Unternehmen ist aber vor allem
China stark an der Mond-Erkundung interessiert.
Anfang des Jahres gelang der große Coup.
Als erstes Land setzte die Volksrepublik die
Raumsonde Chang’e 4 auf der Rückseite des
Mondes ab - eine völlig unerforschte Region.
Das war wirklich eine Premiere und “ein
neues Kapitel in der lunaren Erforschung”,
so die chinesische Weltraumbehörde CNSA.
Aber auch symbolisch hatte das einen großen
Wert, denn die Chinesen demonstrieren so,
dass sie längst auf Augenhöhe mit westlichen
Ländern sind.
Der chinesische Rover soll vor allem im sogenannten
“Mare Imbrium”, also dem “Regenmeer”
des Mondes Bodenproben nehmen.
Die Region stellt das zweitgrößte Mare des
Erdmondes dar: Von der Fläche her ist es
doppelt so groß wie Deutschland.
Wirklich easy wäre der Helium 3-Abbau allerdings
nicht: Der Mondboden muss dafür auf rund
700 Grad aufgeheizt werden - erst so löst
sich das Gas aus dem Regolith.
Chinas Vorstellungen zufolge könnten Roboter
den Abbau übernehmen Ein Rover mit einem
Parabolspiegel auf dem Dach könnte das Sonnenlicht
einfangen.
Nach Berechnungen eines amerikanischen Wissenschaftlers
müssten bis zu 100 Millionen Tonnen Regolith
umgegraben werden, um eine Tonne Helium-3
zu gewinnen.
40 Tonnen Helium bräuchte es dann, um die
USA ein Jahr lang mit Strom zu versorgen.
Nicht wirklich effektiv also, wenn man ehrlich
ist.
Der Transport zur Erde dagegen würde sich
gar nicht mal so problematisch gestalten,
da die Anziehungskraft des Mondes nur etwa
ein Siebtel der Erdanziehungskraft besitzt
und eine Rakete somit nur etwa ein Siebtel
der Schubkraft benötigt.
Alternativ könnten hier auch Weltraumaufzüge
ins Spiel kommen, wie manche Forscherteams
sagen.
An einem 36.000 Kilometer langen Seil könnten
Gondel auf und ab fahren und die Bodenschätze
transportieren.
Wir hatten darüber mal ausführlich bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction berichtet.
Theoretisch sei solch ein Aufzug möglich,
doch es fehle noch an Techniken, um so ein
langes Seil zu fertigen und zudem steht auch
noch die Finanzierungsfrage im Raum.
Das sind also alles Fragen, die noch offen
sind.
Doch fest steht, dass die Chinesen ihre Mond-Erkundung
wirklich Ernst nehmen.
Diese derzeitige Mission ist aber nämlich
nur ein kleiner Zwischenschritt der großen
chinesischen Vision.
Im kommenden Jahr sollen Chang’e-5 und Chang’e-6
zwei Kilo Mondgestein zur Erde bringen.
Seit mehr als 40 Jahren würde dann wieder
Material vom Mond in irdischen Labors analysiert
werden.
Mondgestein hatten bisher nur die Astronauten
von drei sowjetischen Roboter-Sonden und der
sechs Apollo-Landungen mit zur Erde bringen
können.
Die Analysen sollen dann zeigen, ob sich die
im Mond-Boden enthaltenen Rohstoffe für eine
Besiedlung eignen.
Spätestens 2025 soll dann eine Mondbasis
errichtet werden.
Dazu ein Mitglied der der Chinesischen Akademie
für Raumfahrttechnologie "Es wird zuerst
ein unbemannter Mond-Stützpunkt sein, den
wir durch Roboter und künstliche Intelligenz
betreiben werden.
In Zukunft aber sollen dann auch Menschen
auf dem Mond leben können”.
Wow: Kolonie auf dem Mond.
Unbedingt auf dieses Video von Raumzeit Vlog
der Zukunft klicken.
Hier werden Fragen beantwortet: Wie realistisch
ist der Plan und wie sinnvoll.
Also draufklicken, anschauen und abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!